episode 12 ap 12 here we go
[Music]
where's that from mace oh yeah is rough
mmm it's funny I was actually gonna talk
about it anyway okay
office is he last night made it more
contextual yeah
strip clubs found yeah yeah strip clubs
fam yeah talk to me I loved them
yeah who doesn't but like um it's kind
of a love/hate thing
I realized I never realized until
yesterday like it's all about the whole
experience is about for me anyway had I
mean you feel out of you feel
yeah just like before well not before
but like you think like you says I saw
most of ours she's a good dancer
yeah she's a good dancer to give me a
good lap dance than that yeah so um yeah
but boy I don't know him
now so to put it in context so we went
out last night yeah had a good time went
to a club went to a strip club and with
the sushi which is Giustra clubs one was
[ __ ] god-awful absolutely god-awful
and the other was all right miles away
that's not picking up anything this here
is not picking up anything here cuz here
cuz and yes so there was one stripper
there was one stripper I thought she was
fit dynamite I thought she was pf4 she
was sexy so I as soon as I saw her I was
like if I'm getting dance tonight
it's from her right that's certified
even get a dance tonight is from her end
of
and yeah I've got dance from her first
of all you know what you know what she
did she bumped me she [ __ ] hustled me
as well so obviously you know the
pricing structure yeah it was like
twenty four three minutes
sixty four ten minutes yeah yeah yeah so
I knew the menu in it yeah I knew the
menu option and then when when I went to
get dance yeah I was like ah no she said
or have you decided what what how like
how long you want yeah and I was like
just to reconfirm what the options yeah
my girl said oh well it's 60 for a
ten-minute dance or it's 220 for a VIP
dance
that's the only option she gave me she
drives a hustle bro me being polite I
was like 61 that oh I didn't because I
don't know call me old-fashioned bro I
don't want to ruin the whole ambiance
being like just haggling hagglunds is so
ugly to me yeah I hear that but for me
opposite bro so obviously I went in with
I went over no mates and then it was two
of us and into it mm-hmm and then
obviously I didn't know the prices
anyway so I went to movie went to pay
she's like oh one of the chicks is they
are so how would you want to do Barbara
how long for and I was like also what's
the minimum and she's like our 15
minutes I'm thinking I know but it's not
fifty miss you you must know that I know
it's not fifteen minutes why would you
even start with that
yeah you just made yourself look like a
[ __ ] yeah so what the price is I'm
asking you at the prices and then daddy
was like the daddy behind the counter
was like a free for this 6/4 I was like
cool now now you're speaking my language
yeah because I would embarrass you yeah
yeah that's the thing but I'm thinking I
don't want to embarrass her I don't want
to pull her up and be like well I know
you're a liar
yeah because then we're going into the
room on bad time the foetus is ruined
we're going in there on bad terms and so
anyway she bought me secured the 60 yeah
so when in there and obviously
you don't know what to expect but I
thought she's very attractive
yeah I'll probably have a good dance
yeah yeah yeah it was awful
it was awful I'd say I was awful because
she didn't want to be there I can tell
she didn't want to be there and like I
didn't necessarily want to be there much
Eva yeah but like everyone's need to
have a good time in it yeah yeah let me
get lost in the fantasy and like her
dance at the video was all right yeah
but she just did want to be there and
I'm like this is just awkward and she
was going through the motions from I
think I said it last night she's go
through the motion she moved from spot
to spot B to spot C she heard Moo's was
so choreographed yeah and I was just
like I'm dancing number nine yeah you
just you confirmed that I'm dance number
nine yeah
she doesn't really she's not doing it
for you yeah she's just doing it she
won't remember me yeah and it's just
like but to be fed that's the same for
every stripper but I feel like you are
the only guy in the room
um this is what like that's the fun
customer experience yeah yeah man like
when you people say like are good
customer service and all that like it
applies to also all sorts you remember
the good ones you remember the good ones
run because you just like oh that make
person made me feel yeah like it was
about me in here and brush she didn't
make it if I could leave her a [ __ ]
yelp review Advisor Rob I didn't feel it
I was invited in um so that was [ __ ]
that was a waste of money and then so we
came back yeah and then who was it a few
people had had a dance from the other
one the one the one that was sitting
there was all the tattoos oh yeah the
big t one yeah yeah so she was sitting
with us for a while she was throwing
around some banner and stuff and a few a
few of you Lord had dances yeah and
someone suggested to me they are you
should get because I explained that how
awful my previous one is I should get
her she's really good yeah and I'm like
we'll see the reason I said I didn't
enjoy it was because I didn't feel like
it was personal
so there's no way in hell I'm gonna feel
personalized if I in like from the go
before I'm imagining I'm bouncer number
nine yeah but that's still my
imagination yeah I'm I know
no I've dancer number four here yeah
she's just come back all of you I know
I'm got some before yeah there's no way
I'm gonna get that same experience yeah
fam boy was I wrong mmm boy was I wrong
boy was I wrong okay talk to us Rob went
in The Ting I'm like all right let's
just get this over [ __ ] it yes Sharon
let's just get this over with
I'm not paying for it let's just so went
in there she gave me the girlfriend
experience
this is all I want yeah yeah this is all
I wanted the girlfriend experience
no touching nothing but she made me feel
wanted yeah she made me feel like you
know you know is yeah yeah that's what
you have to feel yeah even if you're in
a relation whatever that like it's so
fun and like you you won't even remember
like tomorrow I will remember this trip
yeah of course but what you want in a
strip club experience is you want to
feel like they would [ __ ] you yeah if
the cameras weren't on yeah yeah yeah
right regardless if they would or if
they wouldn't or if you would are you
willing you want to feel like they
would've option yeah there's much this
tension in here and if these cameras
weren't on would be she wanna get that
lips it rough so Lovell lives no I love
exactly what she did even though that's
how pro she was because even though I
know she'd already come back with guys
girls the the pair's all sorts even
though I knew I was dancing them before
her God you were lost I wasn't lost in
the illusion
I was lost in the fantasy rather secured
it yeah I would have given her a tip I
partially secured it I hear that yeah
man it was good so yeah if anyone's a
stripper listening do that do that don't
worry about the technical [ __ ] like lost
in it get lost
make mom feel want to like like when our
friends went in with two chicks
and then one of his chicks stopped
dancing a whole stripper stopped dancing
because the other stripper that she went
him with was she said was ten times
better at dancing and it's like pigmen
I've paid for this experience and you're
not dancing because you're looking at
the other girl and you're you call
yourself a stripper your colleagues your
colleagues your colleagues you're
supposed to be teaming up and making
this double double the experience I'm
doing double the money you're supposed
to do double the experience that's what
you're giving me half run my piece back
run my face back Risa's me
refund me cuz clearly you're not cut out
for this gig yeah man you know car
videos that's the thing even if that's
how you feel inside I'm a customer
brother from we went to the ship one and
I got duped into dancing with that
horrible I remember yeah she bumped her
head on the mirror yeah in the little
room it danced mid dance and like you
just you swerve it if that's what
happens you bump your head you make sure
that was intentional I don't leave you
twist twist your head round and then
like press your whole body yeah yeah lay
it off
Wow she was like she smacked a head and
she was like aah bump my head this is
that this room so small if I was in the
zone which I wasn't yeah if I was Ruben
ruined ruined
she was my god awful good and did anyone
did anyone make reference to that
wildebeast stripper in the first joint
the one with a [ __ ] cloak thing in
the white thing without the black woman
black word with our chair [ __ ] brows
an anime character she looked like a fat
Macy Gray a fat African Macy Gray that's
what she looked like I was appalled
he was getting money she were getting
customers I saw I still go off at least
twice I didn't see that horrific bro and
the other one the one I bumped a head
when we were all chilling together she
came over and was like before the dogs
know after after I washed my hands with
that experience
she came over yeah I was like what did
she say she was chillin chillin chillin
and then she goes oh do you lock mind if
I go chat to those guys over there to
make something
I need to make some money [ __ ] you say
that's before you anything bro do you
what you need to do it why you asking me
for
am I your manager I remember using
you're ruining the experience for
everyone yeah you mind if I go make some
money
Oh what these not have no savvy they
need to go on a course we were saying if
we were female strippers how sick we be
oh yeah and the other girls piped up
saying oh you never know blood was like
I'm lost in a fantasy I know myself I
know our guest I'll be in a moment if I
was a female stripper I'd make I'm sorry
much much money I'll make these man feel
so I wanted I know it's not that easy
it's not as easy you think this is easy
to make it easy if they're saying it's
not as easy as you think like is
actually is easy if I could make it
because boy
I'll make them found masterful wanted
[Music]
yeah that's the thing I will make him
for Madhwani it doesn't matter about the
dancing to Billy yeah obviously gotta
have rhythm
yeah but yeah I'll crush it I'd crush it
you need to request it is this thing
from the pic sorry we're picking up zero
for you I'm here but yet the thing is is
also obviously back on to the strip club
team as a whole hello ladies on in to
the strip club seem like girlfriends
they don't I don't mind going strip club
yeah yeah I see that of course of course
it's what's your view on it I so I feel
like I can understand why girls wouldn't
want their men to go to strip clubs
especially with a group of guys last
night no with the partner you mean I
mean because they just get lost in that
in that euphoria of like oh my god this
is bangin and I feel like the reason why
girls don't want that is because I feel
like they feel like they can't live up
to that experience yeah yeah it kind of
makes it kind of puts pressure on them
to think is if this is what my man likes
and I can't
to come to that what does that make me
yeah it's true and I think a lot the
time as well they have this is almost
like a false paranoia yeah a lot of time
they have like an idea in their head
that the guy has like the urge to go to
strip clubs
yeah like to pick up something he's
missing yeah but I've never had the urge
to go just I just go because we're going
yeah yeah the night yeah yeah yeah and
when I'm when I'm in there like I think
I've been hard like twice yeah I've been
just woke up like a hundred times I
think a bit hard like twice every Tyga's
ready for us
ridded for us chiefly man but yeah like
and I've never been like ah broth like
I'm not getting [ __ ] I hope I need to
go to a strip joint like it's never back
like that it's never the case but yeah
obviously you do get like regulars in
there and stuff and yet they should be
concerned if that's the case yeah that's
true there probably is true yeah man
like I don't like how do I say yeah
obviously I understand when a girlfriend
or a partner doesn't like their mine go
into strip clubs like on a regular basis
yeah but like sometimes it's just a bit
of fun like you know when you've got
like guys like on a stag do or something
yeah then like mans like I can't go I
can't go in the strip club I can't go in
a shut up you can't go shut up you just
go man not to go but yeah bro
I don't see the big deal because like
it's just a bit of fun and it's
literally just a bit fun like I would
have I wouldn't give a [ __ ] if any girl
I was seeing went to a strip club or
even went to a male strip club
I wouldn't feel any type of way now
there'll be a lot of girls I think that
would say oh it's different what they
say is [ __ ] dice always [ __ ] it is
always different for them it's not
different it's exactly the same thing
you're going there because it's exciting
it's fight is something new something
different and you're not going there cuz
you want to fight these guys just go in
it for the pleasure and getting lost in
that whole source that's exactly the
same reason why guys go to strip clubs
well I don't know about all guys or some
guys go in there to find love but but
some guys fall in love um but like
the thing is as well like a guy would
never obviously a guy can't cheat with a
stripper anyway yeah
excuse me I can't use triple go no
stinkin this kind of follows up on the
same thing women are worse brough
forwards Butler's in the buff oh my god
so story time I'll never forget that
story time oh Jesus
way back when to set the scene man so
with me if you had were struggling eyes
struggling ah is the food on the table
we we started looking for like quick
ways to make money and it started off
being a male escort in it yeah start off
being a male escort
look it into that yeah and was the whole
kind of uh I don't I like you know he
the the the stories are you don't have
to [ __ ] the women yeah like you to take
him on a day make it feel nice and
you'll get paid like a grand and even
stuff like that all that [ __ ] yeah
so looked into that that never came to
fruition and then we moved on to like
stripping and we fake came across
company called Butler's in the buff
which is like naked I was gonna say
topless night with toplessness naked
being as being a naked Butler yeah so we
applied we had to do an interview via
Skype was our perfo you know I was
actually been named will have yeah that
was his name him yeah boss man of the
company would Skype you and you had to
chat to him for a minute just to make
sure you can hold a conversation then
you have to get your [ __ ] kit off let
him take screenshots that's what you
used to do you stand in front of the
laptop and cameras on you and they were
like cool front side back side cetera
cetera cetera yeah right decent and then
you have to tell him a funny anecdote a
little funny story I remember that
so corny I remember that it was common
why I said finally indefinitely terrible
I think I used the one you used because
you did yours first and when we do it in
TV first and then you told me that I had
to think of one yeah what did you use
like this a 1 I call me but it was
usually the same one I use the same one
do something similar okay I was gonna
say take on the same one it was somehow
I would have been I just heard yes I
have to do it a little funny anecdote
and then he's a very cool so you got the
job so what we had to do was they sent
us are kidding the post and all we would
have is an apron to wear mmm literally
literally an apron and a bowtie apron
bowtie and coughs cough because baby
wrists and my cuffs would slide up my
forearms all the time I was such a yeah
so yeah yeah so what we had to do you
get an email on a Tuesday and to be will
like our James we had we need you in
Scunthorpe on Saturday that was our
first scuffle was our first kick need
one Scunthorpe and sad day we've got a
hen dude drive up there doesn't matter
if he's an hour away three hours away
drive up there get naked and you just
searched on pain and [ __ ] once these
hoes got a few drinks in them they were
on some different [ __ ] they were on a
different thing there was some different
[ __ ] there was some cheating [ __ ] and
this is a Hindu yeah and it was always
the bride-to-be that was the dirtiest
slag of them are not always actually but
a good couple the one that was about to
be Wed there you slag of them all yeah
and like that pales in comparison to a
guy go into a strip club yeah they keep
that [ __ ] um yeah without a shadow of a
doubt it was crazy and then you rock up
and it would just be you naked in a
house full of women full of 20 women
minimum
drunken horny uh what was the one we
went to where they had the hot tub in
Darby ah cuz it was just meant to be me
your fingers it just meant to be me and
then how do we
I get that I went with you we didn't
tell HQ that you were coming yeah but we
just jumped when we knocked on the door
I told the lady uh my colleague had a
job that like a couple miles away called
canceled yeah so we thought you'd get
two for one if you want and obviously
she was like yeah yeah yeah yeah so came
in year that was a fun word that was a
very thing that was a fun one that was a
light-hearted one that one didn't get to
my times I tell you stay over us have a
drink you know I can't drive in their
eyes just a little spare rubes the year
they were disgraced what I remember was
one time I had one in Northampton and it
was just women everywhere as soon as I
got there they made me lay flat sprayed
whipped cream all over my stomach and
took turns licking it off and then
they'd pour like champagne and my belly
button and I suck our [ __ ] it was
disgusted I didn't know me didn't mean I
was a strange guy and it was disgrace
the experience they just wanted you for
the experience that's it
brother they lost their heads dirty
[ __ ] cheats we're gonna worse I don't
care they are that's from that they that
made me realize we've another one this
this was probably 2012 so we're talking
a child big member till when I went to
one this was probably the worst one
where I went there and the bride to be
you I think she used to be a stripper
and so did her maid of honor and they
were just chatting to me I went outside
yeah so it was outside in their garden
and then she said have you ever had a
hard-on it on a job before and I was
like god night mmm and then she was like
today
today's the day bet I was I don't think
so they tried they [ __ ] tried and you
know what the funny thing is is that we
used to chat so much faster oh my [ __ ]
so I'm like yeah yeah yeah obviously
yeah we'll go around there [ __ ] these
girls and all that
is my name until you get there to get
there my heart was racing I don't know
how to handle that be thin but one time
I specifically remember it's time I told
you in it when I was in the going to get
changed the job was finished yeah I was
going upstairs to get changed and one of
the women was how hard James you need
help getting changed she was at the Bob
this hour remember like it was yesterday
she was at the stairs I was at the top
of the stairs the bathroom was literally
just in front of the stairs I had my
hand on the door handle going in and she
was like James do you need do you need
help getting changed and I was like no
I'm all right
and she was like no do you'd help
getting changed if I was a real man I
would have been a hell yes comes like
this [ __ ] help me help me brother I
wasn't a man I wasn't a man I was 19 20
maybe and I was like no I'm good I'm
good be thank you thank you mrs. farm
okay
yeah I was terrified I didn't [ __ ]
anyone I didn't [ __ ] anyone no neither
did I leave it the [ __ ] I did if like
at whyyyy I didn't do I did for a summer
you did it for a sign yes i'm i was
sacked [ __ ] sacked your site for
sexual misconduct no that's a lie I've
got sucks because I felt I think I
remember the one I went on and they said
I think they reported back saying I
wasn't what they expected in terms of
life I wasn't out there enough Oh 30 in
I wasn't giving them an experienced
reason means because it was [ __ ]
freezing it was in a hole and it was
cold that's why I quit her dad was
freezing so I quit their job no wait I'm
there's no [ __ ] way I'm doing this it
was so cold I quit that job I'm in my
last job
they sent me to Birmingham and this part
had rented out pretty much a whole club
there was four of them in there so the
middle of December God four of them in
there and obviously the club don't have
heating yeah this is a club there's
always body heat net so he had the
aircon on automatically
so it's middle of December in an empty
club with four [ __ ] in there
and it was
freezing but fam I think was this big it
was freezing worse I was like never do
this again I'm never doing this again
that was the worst [ __ ] hated it but
yeah man
long story short we've not crud are on
this disgusting never seen anything like
it then and you'd never end of sorry to
cut you off that kind of behavior
obviously flip the table
a woman stripper comes to a guy stag do
yeah yeah a house yeah imagine just
telling this horror story yeah a guy a
woman or a story a woman goes to a house
cuz sometimes there'll be a house in the
middle of the woods yeah yeah I remember
I never have signal because it just went
out like a party house of course like an
airbnb pie house so I'd go there and
then like yeah imagine a woman driving
into the middle of the woods yeah to get
a key off and there's a house or 20 man
in there drunk and horny and they just
lay her down start licking her one [ __ ]
bit my ass she bit hard and she told her
yes to come and I was like darn no
violate me no yeah cuz that's true -
rape yes everyone in the house go to
jail yeah yeah
because I'm a guy it's fine it's fine
well you really push your why complain
him for it's such a double standard yeah
man oh you're hot older women buying
your ass
hey Sasha don't was the poor boy nah man
it's a double standard obvious I'm not
complaining but it is so for sure yeah
women eaters fur me because it's crazy
because a girl's messy hen do is worse
than a guy's messy stag do in my opinion
Oh from what we've seen oh god what you
see and girls are an absolute and it's
always like it's never the buff buff
ones that aren't cried it's always the
ones that have ever got a full-blown
husband kids or that they're just on the
most because the midlife crisis you want
to live a different experience just that
one night and never speak of it again
they do their own absolute crud it's
graceful man they disgraced the
disgusting yeah it's good for them but
yeah man it was crazy it was a funny
perience it was funny man it was the
best Oh God the best jobs I've had was
so fun heito very well as well it did
pay well very well for at that time of
our lives
mm very well oh my god my chest guys I'm
ill I am so ill I've got the flu I'm
putting this this episode's gonna go up
probably tonight
oh really so someone give me feedback if
you've got any flu remedies that are
[ __ ] please tell me I'm dying I'm
[ __ ] dying oh my god just a really
quick one on I just want to shout out
that they knew the new listeners we've
got a new viewers we've got oh no
obviously you said you sent me this
that's all the time and then it just
baffles me when we see different
countries like you got Finland we got
Austria we got obviously New Zealand
Australia as a big one for now so shall
you Australian girls are always tuning
in every week you know might not just be
girls from come on you know I say I know
I know you mean I'm Italy Belgium Dubai
Germany Canada's reppin USA is reppin
obviously what the most from the UK but
it's just mind-blowing man like is man's
like this we started this say yeah this
is probably a nice thing coming towards
the end of the year stuff for that man
it's nice to do a little shower man cuz
yeah we started this 29 for September
you know was the first episode and it's
become an integral part of our lives and
yeah it's just crazy to show that
although like sometimes you look at like
the Instagram and stuff like that you
know man we ain't got even that many
followers like no one's really
interested when you look online yeah and
see like the audio stats and stuff like
that you're just like [ __ ] you inhale
broth the one that like baffles me is
when cuz on YouTube I can see how long
people listen to it yeah so the average
yeah I used to have a YouTube channel
I'm not gonna tell you what it's called
but it was just me I used to like for a
few films and [ __ ] and he got a lot of
views but the average was like 30
seconds max maybe sometimes like 12
seconds so people just click it watch my
face for 12 seconds my father's guy yeah
for us it's like 25 minutes average oh
wow these bonkers yeah that's and the
minute the episodes like 40 minutes long
yeah this half the episode done so
people are intrigued man in yeah and
with global global actually popping
worldwide so yeah big thank you to
everyone who's staying interested
staying tuned we're gonna try and sort
out the schedules a little bit better
cuz I know they're all over the place
sometimes they come out Sunday sometimes
they come out [ __ ] Monday sometimes
they come on Tuesday i'ma try sort out
we asked a few weeks ago yeah
Mary get into it now man slacking about
the female insecurities yeah I remember
that we could most interested there any
most interest in one that we've got back
it was actually no no no no sorry sorry
sorry sorry sir I really did the female
insecurities did no no no we did it a
little bit yeah but basically yeah we
got those of a few Minds Akutan back
yeah but one of the listeners asked us
if we could talk about our view on
[ __ ] work colleagues you sleep poking
the payroll poking the parents a little
ooh I've got her in here poking the
payroll can the payroll I'll let you
take the lead on it ah well in my
industry it's hard not to purely because
you see them day in day out five days a
week obviously like any other job but I
went along as I was obviously if you
know what I do
I went along last I was I don't what you
do for in the kind of place I work or
work in hospitality
so restaurants and it's everyone
wouldn't know everyone in hospitality in
the she knows it's anonymous for guys
just guys and girls just link
in within the same building whoever and
when I first started in hospitality it
was new to me like I was like what why
does so many like work into work
relationships like it's so it's so crazy
to me but it just makes more sense the
longer and longer longer you working on
solitude the more and more and more
anymore you see them that's all that's
all you know kind of things you know
it's hard to find someone else outside
of that because literally the scheduling
of trying to pattern a day or something
with someone that doesn't 9:00 to 5:00
or someone that does opposite shifts is
as hard as [ __ ] so that's the reason why
there are love into work relationships
and stuff and I'm people just [ __ ]
everyone and whatever and you'll be the
most random the most random people
[ __ ] mmm the most random people hmm
oh my god the most random is weird bro
is so weird staff parties as well
everyone gets loose on a stop by brav
hospital rinse off ice I I used to get
so jealous with the stories used to tell
from everyone was getting laid by heart
everyone everyone's lips on everyone
everyone's bringing out all the guns
like girls that I've even know looked at
me fat were coming up to man just touch
him and all of that I don't know what it
is about Christmas PI's sends people
loopy
send them West West you've got a few
free drinks and ice it bribe that's it
they lose the plot everyone wants to
[ __ ] and they don't care they just don't
care it doesn't it's like tomorrow
doesn't exist it's like we're gonna all
die tonight so [ __ ] what happened yeah
like what stays yeah what happens here
stays here is here right sister Chris
was playing hi you Sookie gasps for
Christmas pies gasps same every year
phone from your ones used to pop I'm so
jealous I wait for the story because you
haven't I remember used to have it in
January and I would always be so [ __ ]
jealous always were always sick Oh
genitals flying every always sick always
sick yeah man it's fingers as well about
the work team yeah is that I was
thinking about this the other day I was
talking to someone about it yeah and
it's like
but no no we spoke about it on an
episode a few weeks ago yeah
and wish we were spoken about like
people being interested people having to
be interesting yeah and it's like you
get loads of little relationships and
people [ __ ] in work because you spent
so much time with them that sometimes
even if you didn't initially find them
attractive you start spent ages actually
[ __ ] this person yeah because you're so
cool like yeah yeah he is gassed me now
I want to [ __ ] you yeah well actually
[ __ ] this person and then they just do
they always do it just happens but I
have this there's people in every office
where every space I've ever been in
there's people [ __ ] 100% you don't
make sense is it doesn't it doesn't so
I'd like to actually answer the question
what was the question what was it good
well now what's your view once you're
viewing it yeah if it's a good thing on
my personal view on it is if you're new
to that kind of stuff in terms of like I
have a new top salary or new to working
in an office blah blah we like mixed
males and females like a good ratio then
your eyes are gonna open trust me
because you're gonna find out [ __ ] that
you never expected but the more and more
you get used to it the more most are
working in that kind of environment that
industry trust me you are gonna you are
gonna find something you're gonna want
to bang and it's just it's just more
about the the accessibility of it you I
mean because you see them all at the
time yeah them every day yeah
at least you're gonna see them three
times a week yeah and the tension just
starts to build and build and build and
build then one night you were if it
drinks and it's uh one night you all go
for drinks on a Sunday
the cheeky she lost on a Sunday and then
yeah
she keeps fluttering in the petros
afterwards just a seal off the night and
there you know babes you're coming back
or I'm coming to yours because we're not
playing games
we're not playing games anymore
hilarious and it's facts it happens we
can we cannot study bonkers is crazy
that's bonkers crap but the bad thing
about it let's say you just want to
chill you just wanna have fun the bad
thing about is about the next day
everyone's gonna know everyone that was
out is gonna know and then they're gonna
start telling people so let's say for
example if you're at galas
and you're trying to not necessarily
[ __ ] everyone but you're just a
flirtatious kind of person yeah which is
my character I'm a flirtatious person I
want yes just me yeah
so if I have actively [ __ ] someone at
work and everyone knows about it and
that Reubens not necessarily my chance
is to [ __ ] everyone else but I feel like
if I am being my normal self which is
flirtatious they're gonna think I'm just
trying to [ __ ] them yeah your reputation
Zac that's what doesn't you just
rephrase exactly I would feel like they
think I'm a predator yes not how I am
that's just my nature
yeah it's naturally a flood yeah so it's
it's it's one of them once a
double-edged sword it's hard not to
balance out but you just gotta play the
game really you gotta play it well you
gotta understand that people were never
gonna have sex in your industry
mm-hm especially especially hospitality
special a good point man you don't drink
as well it's an app city rap [ __ ] you
know you go out almost we go out every
week every week on it's not life am I
talking about I don't know how you live
that life my life is because you look
forward to it
mmm it's literally the only thing you
look forward to sometimes a pop yeah
yeah I bet I was just like a relief yeah
to be fair it makes a lot of sense I
remember when I used to my [ __ ] when
my [ __ ] mom used to make me work so
when I used to come home for me uni for
the summer and my mum used to make me
work anywhere and within the shitty
place where we lived only work going was
like warehouses where stuff factories
and warehouses and [ __ ] and you get paid
weekly yeah and it was such a stressful
tiring [ __ ] week every week yeah as soon
as it got to the weekend yeah you're
letting loose wives to spend my paycheck
yeah every week drinks so you can I can
definitely imagine if there was someone
in that environment with me yeah and you
just you're like you go out with them
and it's just girls and guys I can
imagine every everyone's [ __ ]
everyone's [ __ ] everyone [ __ ] I
like inside like I love hearing about
office romances they make me [ __ ]
laugh it's is why especially when people
trying to keep it on a sly one yeah when
people think that other people don't
know yeah [ __ ] cracks me bro I found
out some guy I don't even know if it's
there no they're never gonna listen to
it so I'm never gonna say names but I
found out that someone at my spot
it's [ __ ] someone at my that's
basically two people are [ __ ] at work
yeah yeah [ __ ] at work but it's TP
with that you would have never ever ever
put together said aware yeah so the girl
is like the female advocate of don't
[ __ ] where you sleep
oh okay yeah but now she's a [ __ ]
hypocrite right now I mean yeah
absolutely
yeah because of what I found out mmm
she's Isis ah it's mad it's mad she's
[ __ ] a guy that was [ __ ] another
girl but he cheated on her so he cheated
on the girl that he was with yeah they
broke up whatever whatever whatever so
everyone knows that
yeah well they did they work together as
well they still work together so they
didn't before but they do now oh not
together okay
okay yeah that make sense yeah yeah so
when he cheated they didn't work
together no okay okay but any side work
okay what are some different floors yeah
but now the advocate of don't [ __ ] we
asleep he's not [ __ ] to my man that
would T it on brick man it's just it's
all it's all the tangled webs bro it's
all it's all crazy sodding session they
love the spice of it they love then is
forbidden yeah he's forbidden root
everyone wants forbidden fruit everyone
wants forbidden fruit Eve man just like
bro she set the scene set the scene is
crazy she kicked us off bro they love
the spice of it he's mad
is mad oh boy I think that was a cheeky
short ones you want to wrap it yeah yeah
man yeah man yeah man on to the next
until next